what's going on Wolfgang today we got
some news that could be potential
spoilers for Avengers four officially
there's no way to really know if this is
a spoiler for Avengers four but if you
are trying to avoid all spoilers here's
your warning real quick just want to
talk about the infinity war blu-ray
giveaway a few of you have been asking
me some questions so I just wanted to
clarify one winner has already been
chosen brah or draw from YouTube in
order to enter on YouTube all you have
to do is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below what you
think of the video and what your
favorite superhero is and you can do
that on each one of my videos and I will
be picking one winner specifically from
my Instagram or Twitter account so if
you want an extra chance to win be sure
to follow me on social media so
something was noticed that could
possibly give away a plot detail about
Avengers 4 and what that plot detail is
is that Toni will end up meeting Cherie
and going to a condom the reasoning
behind this thinking is because of an
interview that Robert Downey jr. did for
Avengers infinity war that was filmed at
the same time Avengers 4 was being
filmed there are actually a few
giveaways in this interview that lead us
to believe that Tony Stark will meet
Sheree and be in Wakanda so as you can
see here the background of this
interview is what Conda you can compare
it to this picture of Sheree where
they're pretty much in the same place
and again this interview was filmed
after infinity war had already been shot
and Avengers 4 was currently being
filmed so Avengers 4 is currently being
filmed and the background of where this
interview took place is Wakanda that's
one reason to believe that Tony Stark
will be in Wakanda but also check this
out look how Robert Downey jr. looks
he's got the blond hair and the gray
beard
this is his Avengers 4 look do you
recall the leaked photos that came out
not too long ago from the set of
Avengers 4 compare the two this is how
he looks in the leaked phone
and this is also how he looks in the
interview so this interview was filmed
at the same time that Avengers 4 was
being filmed and he's wearing the same
clothes that he's wearing in the leaked
photo of the set of Avengers 4 and the
background of the interview is what
Conda so clearly Tony Stark at some
point in Avengers 4 goes to what condom
so this leaves us with the question why
does Tony start go to Wakanda wow he's a
kid
it seems like I'm always thanking you
for something we don't do that here you
could list a ton of reasons for starters
most of the Avengers that survived are
currently in Wakanda at the end of
infinity war that and it's clear that
what Kaunas technology is more advanced
than Bruce banners and Tony Stark's we
found that out when Bruce Banner was at
the Avengers headquarters and basically
said that he didn't have the technology
there to take the mine stone out of
visions head but then they went to
Wakanda and sure he had the technology
so it's possible that he goes there so
they can try and figure out time travel
together or it could be possible that
sure he did something with the mind
stone whatever the reason is it sure
does look like Tony Stark and Sheree
will be teaming up in Avengers 4 what do
you all think about this new information
and if you think it makes sense why do
you think Tony Stark is going to Akhanda
let me know everything you're thinking
in the comments below don't forget about
the giveaway subscribe like comment and
find me on social media thank you so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you
[Music]